з
дружиною пекти а звідки ви самий бік
поля будуть
гантелі зазвичай а
там повз таке в готелі
готель отримано як самий threeway цей
стародавній а
я в книгу а ви чіпали била-біла
маленький збір урожаю слава україні
слава
слава нації
смерть ворогам
Україна
я побачила на 33
понад усе
тільки щось леку їж привіт потрібно
говорити
з дідом приїдемо тобі
коли
жителі підкажіть
чоловік
можна тільки будь ласка швидше тут
був у справах та фішки у вас на сьогодні
план справи ну спочатку треба заглянути
незручний. там диванами я не в неї не
дуже подобається у них пружини густа не
застрягати але потім потрібно за продуктом
кому з'їздити в що дали тобто і .
потім потрібно заглянути в улюблений магазин
дружини носити що є на . потім потрібно
заскочити в швиденько завали своє б на
пил з-під нігтів тайриз чи . не
знаю навіщо було жак переіменовай і
увечері думаю можна на вечерю з дітьми у
смачної. зеленою я відповів це все
добре дякую ваша
основна маса повинна перебувати в масі
внизу щоб хтось жив добре там що
людина повинна на нього працювати, а щоб
100 чоловік зона добре не повинна
працювати мільйон ось все дуже просто ми
їх але ця маса внизу ми повинні працювати
на тих які нагорі це ж
пірамідальна система звичайна добре але
ця маса ж може жити комфортно
навіщо не для цього масу існує не
для цього існує держави вона
існує для того, щоб тримати масу
у покорі змушувати працювати на
себе dance
перекручуючи
далі крізь і
бенкетував вами
чепець
ви чисті втрати мети слове чах
unique до texture for soil
чіпа like 40 білий
чим так собі лаври
чорт 10 лев юз
селяни де
мяу council стовпчик вас потягне та
ватка та канави таким собі east and towns of
time
delay winter ризиком та
[музика]
російських пішов би на російську
втратив де
[музика]
подарунок
[оплески]
Ну добре
так ні ні давай рубай міні стриптиз куру
з пацанами на озері про хайр найточніша
будь ласка добра скажемо несусь таки
радуючий завив імені тіней на заводить
скажіть нажіть на заводи коли бачу тебе
у майках я
твою матір манатки не заводить, але те частіше
на таке часто мозок
відпочивав а ну повтори хабіб відкинув вони
душа
продовжено
за кетчуп
рахунок
я нині
піднято
весь повели так і до бою так мене вся
дозрівання
[оплески]
зустрічає китайські сни луги байва
готовність за ліцензією супроводжує ви
ще дуже США йдуть у пекло і ракети
війна купол
таки не прийму заразу на
посадку
зайняті увійти
ми прилетіли добрі
[музика]
до речі глинами тут всього місця максик
ранзі
добрих розморожування все це інструмент і
ночами
росії люблю кури бігають як люди
метушаться пізніше арки проїжджають ну люди в
шоці ока вже волосся
[музика]
я свій він боявся від плакався від боявся
взагалі [ __ ]
[музика]
одні він мене хто і
5-го ще один великий я війна лісу батьківщин
хто atari дорогої дати йде до Європи
що там америка сейфе
вогнем
майбутнє майбутнє я не можу дивитися на них
майбутнє це вже немає я думаю нас краще
ніж у Європі що саме культурнішою
більш цивільні мені здається, що у них
Європі твориться страшно мені здається
вона соус а що там діється як з дітьми
звертаються вони без дівчинка робить
хлопчика з хлопчика справа дівчинку для
мене це взагалі жах кошмар цьому ми до
цього ніколи не були в Європі немає
так
[музика]
а і шорти
ай ай
йаран.
[оплески]
[музика]
а я забула хто я гори вдома у ти блазень
[оплески]
[музика]
руками не повністю сухий знайшов що ти
таке кажеш коза вже брешуть темі
повис той карбованець завтра на 89 ще я ваблю
випробують розуму я віку служачи брешу свічки ви
би в охоронцем сільпо віддав на картах
таро місяця не читаю на ту повісу та кетчуп
а я п'яний і за кримом чіпа поїхала
булава вранці вже шульги porsche випробував
ти чого листівка теж вояка я не
може і до 3 23 тис російська вся кава
і на мага і типу романи ти мешканець
херсона на свій бік він ще один
аргумент покарає шакша херсон
зізнається в Росії то у карсон segundo
дешевий газ зв'язала 4 з нас правді так і
їй вона владному та зведу тему вирвано
весь я розум з друзями та ведмедиком mty ми
добре ну ось вони вийшли на центральну
площа місця та й відривалася свою порцію
газу
сліз заточував обрізку що одне
халява ну дранка пролітає план вони нас
не можна зрозуміти він тут я висунув і
близько половини 500 це ввібрав і підлітав
з них штани, а ми змогли
танки кого ти там ticket вогонь тепер
ти ковані б ми не потребуватиме їжа по
драмі виманити
хоче херсонських до вас шок і не me
alone нас і київ так мало їм ялиці
стільці
інакше сонячні зайчики
[музика]